game of thrones was notorious for its  unflinching depictions of violence and  house of the dragon follows suit in the  first episode prince damon's gold cloaks  try to rid king's landing of its  criminal element by using extra judicial  torture and death as a deterrent demon's  men cut off hands and do much worse this  public spectacle of wanton brutality  wasn't just dreamt up by show creators  they're the precise punishments doled  out by damon and his gold cloaks in  author george r martin's firing blood in  the book and it seems the series damon's  brand of justice makes him popular  thanks to claims that he's making the  city safer